MALE SPEAKER: Thanks for
coming out to today's talk
with authors at Google.
I stumbled across a documentary
called "Crime After Crime"
on Netflix one night,
and I was really
quickly sucked into this movie.
I was really surprised by it,
and it's a heart wrenching
story about a
woman named Debbie.
And without getting
into the gory details--
because I'm not
a lawyer-- Debbie
was convicted of the murder
of her abusive boyfriend
and sentenced to 25
years to life in prison.
But under a new
law that was passed
in the state of California
that allows cases involving
battered women to
be reconsidered,
two lawyers took on the task of
getting Debbie out of prison.
Joshua and his colleague Nadia
got to work setting her free,
and they hit basically
every conceivable obstacle
you can imagine.
And what was supposed to
be-- from what I understand--
a relatively short case,
which I think means somewhere
in the six month
range, ended up taking
eight years of pro bono work.
And they could've
quit at any point.
They have families, and
wives, and all of these things
that make you not
to do pro bono work.
But their unwavering dedication
and commitment for justice
drove them through the better
part of a decade of this work,
and it's exactly
the qualities that
made me reach out to Joshua in a
complete shot in the dark email
and that-- to my
surprise-- worked out.
So "Crime After Crime" screened
on the Oprah Winfrey Network
and in theaters nationwide.
The film was an official
selection of the 2011 Sundance
Film Festival, has won 25
awards, and more recently,
he's authored his memoir "Free
Spirit: Growing Up On The Road
And Off The Grid".
Hitchhiking for years
around the American West
with a WIC and welfare
mother in the '80s,
Safran didn't attend
school until sixth grade,
living in buses, Utopian
communes, on a tree stump,
and even in an ice cream truck.
Eventually, his mother
married an abusive alcoholic
ex-American
guerrilla fighter who
made Safran's life unbearable.
So Joshua shared his story
with NPR, BBC, CBS, and Fox,
and he's been around the
Bay Area quite a bit.
And he's here to share
his story with us today.
So without further ado,
here's Joshua Safran.
JOSHUA SAFRAN: Thank you.
Thank you to Brian.
Can you hear me in
the back all right?
Okay.
So thank you Brian.
I think it's a
testament strangely
of the power of the internet
that I was at home one evening,
and somewhere out in
the ether, this movie
was living in the
land of Netflix.
And suddenly I got this
email, and here we are today.
And I want to thank
Brian for reaching out.
One of the big questions that
came up as part of my advocacy
work on behalf of Deborah--
this battered woman who
was serving life in
prison-- is why you?
Why this large, white, hairy
man representing this African
American woman from
South Central LA
who had been convicted
of killing her batterer?
And why did you stick
with the case for so long?
And I used to give a
lot of false reasons--
which made me seem better and
cooler than I really was--
like because in the pursuit
of justice we cannot pause
for anything, we
have to move forward,
and because I'm dedicated.
And some of the reasons
were truer than others,
including the fact
the Debbie is and was
an incredibly charismatic
person and really
made you want to advocate
for her when you met her.
But there was a deeper
reason, and it was one
that I wasn't really
willing to talk about.
But Debbie's case
and representing
her was an important
transformative
experience for me, and I'll step
back for a moment and just say,
I'm happy to be back
on the west coast.
I've been travelling
on a book tour.
I've been on the
east coast and was
surprised to find that
people still keep up
with the Joneses, 1950s style.
So it's like everyone
has to have the latest
car, and the bigger house,
and move to the fancier
neighborhood, and in Miami, get
the latest cosmetic surgery,
which is very strange for me.
And I was trying to explain
to someone at the Miami
book fair-- one
of my hosts-- how
it's different out
in the Bay Area,
and she said, well,
how do you keep up
with the Joneses
in the Bay Area?
And I said, well, if you
had been the first one
to sell pot to the
Symbionese Liberation Army,
or if you learned
how to brew tea
from a forgotten
tribe in Myanmar, that
would give you street cred.
That would give you
bragging rights.
That's really what we value.
And I say that because
my wife Leah who's
here-- for many years really
had a lot of street cred
in Berkeley, because
she grew up in and out
of a hot tub in Big
Sur, California.
Her yard at her
home was littered
with clay sculptures
of female genitalia.
In fact, the first
time I went to her home
and met her parents, I
tripped over something.
And I looked down and said,
is that a giant clitoris?
And Leah's mother
said, oh, good for you.
Great.
So Leah knew though that she
had met the right person when
she met me, because
she said, you're
the first person
I've ever met who
has a better
childhood than I did.
You've really got the street
cred for all of the reasons
that Brian mentioned, including
living in an ice cream truck.
And Leah for years said,
you've got to write your story.
Who else had these experiences?
It's so strange.
We all know about
the 1960s and all
these counter-cultural rainbow
warriors who went off and lived
in these communes,
but we don't hear
about the aftermath of
all that, the dark side
of the Age of Aquarius.
What happened to their children?
And I was interested
in telling this story
and writing about
it, but I couldn't
for a number of reasons,
including the fact
that the second
half of my childhood
were a series of incredibly
embarrassing and humiliating
experiences that I had
that I didn't want anyone
to know about.
So with that, I decided
not to become a writer,
but to become a lawyer.
It was my attainment
of the American dream.
When I was 25 years
old, I graduated
from UC Berkeley School of Law,
and I got an unbelievable offer
to work at a large
corporate law firm
where I met my friend
Renee who's here today.
We had offices from
London to Tokyo,
and I felt like I
was really someone.
I'd arrived.
We had these beautiful
white carpets,
and if you spilled
something on the carpet,
a guy would literally
run out of a closet,
and clean it up in front of
you, and disappear again.
I had my own corner office
with a name plaque on it
with my name.
And on the first day, my
secretary came, and said,
I don't mind.
I'm happy to do your dry
cleaning for you if you'd like.
And I nodded.
In my mind, I was like I know
dry cleaning has something
to do with laundry,
and I don't think
I own anything drycleanable.
But I was like, thank you.
Thank you very much.
And as I listened to the resumes
and biographies of the people
around me, I felt
very out of place.
My previous work
experience had been
as a janitor to work
my way through college,
and then before that
driving large combines,
harvesting peas in rural
Washington state, where
I had ended up.
So I was trying to
fit in and trying
to do well, and
about six months in,
I began to feel a
certain hollowness,
a certain emptiness
in the work that I
was doing as I was fighting one
Fortune 500 company on behalf
of another over $20 million that
neither of them really needed.
And when an opportunity
to represent
a battered women serving life in
prison for killing her batterer
came, I leap at the
opportunity without consciously
knowing why.
I just, yeah that's a project
that I want to be involved in.
One of the strange things
about prisons in California,
they're almost as hard to get
into as they are to get out of,
so it took me five months
to get security clearance
to get into the prison to
finally meet this client.
And I was a little
naive, a young lawyer.
And I sat down with
her, and I was like OK,
your job is to talk, and
I'm going to tell your story
and get you out of here,
and together we'll do this.
And you got to be really
candid with me and trust me.
I'm your lawyer.
And this woman looked at me.
Debbie looked at me.
And she said, so
you basically want
me to tell you all of the most
humiliating horrible things
that have ever happened
to me in my entire life
so that you can make
them a public document.
And I was like, yeah,
that's the plan.
And not surprisingly, she had
a hard time disclosing to me
and telling me about the
experiences that she had had,
until almost a year
went by, and I still
felt like she wasn't
really being truthful.
She wasn't remembering
a lot of things
that I assumed that she
really did remember.
And finally she said
look, you're a man,
and a lot of the
things that happened
to me, all these horrible
things that happened to me
happened at that hands of a man.
And it's hard for me to
just tell you these things.
And I said, well,
can you tell me
something that was maybe
funny, or ironic, or strange,
something that's not
as humiliating to you?
And the memory that she
chose was an important one.
She said, when he
was done whipping me,
he would get raw
steaks, and put them
on my welts to bring
down the swelling.
And it was funny, because
it was dead flesh.
It was dead meat, but it
was giving me new life.
And also he was the batterer,
but he was also the healer,
and it was strange that way.
And the memory of the raw meat
was a real trigger for me,
and I broke right through the
attorney client relationship.
And I said, oh, I
forgot about the meat.
And for me, it was funny,
because we were vegetarians.
To kill and eat an
animal was murder.
You would never
ever eat an animal,
but it was somehow OK for my
stepfather to beat the hell out
of my mother, and
we had meat on hand
to bring down the swelling
on her cheekbone on her face
so she could be presentable.
And Debbie, my client, looked
at me like you're not my lawyer.
You're like me.
What's going on here?
And she began asking
me all these questions.
And the next thing
I knew she was
taking my statement,
if you will.
And I had this
strange realization
that I'd never talked about the
experiences I'd had as a kid,
not even with my mother--
with whom I experienced them
all-- and my first
therapy moment
was in a maximum
security prison for women
where my therapist
was a convicted
killer in the shadow of the
sniper tower through the razor
wire.
And that was my first moment of
talking about the experiences
that I'd had in the second
half of my childhood.
And Debbie after that
said, I felt in that day
that we were like a
couple of war veterans
and that we were rolling
up our sleeves to compare
our scars-- both
figurative and literal--
and that's when I trusted you.
So I stumbled into
doing the right thing.
Subsequently, I talked to
seasoned criminal defense
attorneys who were
like, huge mistake.
You never befriend your client.
That was totally unprofessional.
What were you thinking?
But it turned out to be
an important mistake,
because at that point, Debbie
was willing to disclose to me.
And we really talked
with one another.
And at that point,
once I had the courage
to talk about this story,
I began to feel like, well,
maybe I could write
about these things
and tie that into my advocacy.
And I came to this
realization that the reason
in one way that I was
really doing this case
was to prove to my
10-year-old self
that I was finally strong
enough and courageous enough
to stand up for someone
who is being battered,
even though it was
many years later.
And shortly thereafter, we
began to have media inquiries.
We had raised a lot of
attention with Debbie's case.
We ended up disqualifying
all 1,000 attorneys
of the Los Angeles District
Attorney's office for conflicts
of interest, which was
a really big story.
And we got a call from the
San Francisco Chronicle
who said, well, we want to do
a profile on the lawyers, you
and your partner.
And I said, no, I
don't want to do that,
because I knew that
the question was going
to be, well, what motivated
you to take this case?
And I didn't want
to go into that.
And a couple weeks later,
I told that to Debbie
as we were doing an
update, and she said, well,
why don't you want
to do the story?
You should do the story.
It'd be great.
And I was like, no,
it should really
be about the client,
not the lawyer.
And she was like, are you
afraid to talk about your life
and what happened in your life?
And I said, no, no.
I'm not afraid.
And Deb is a very
perceptive person.
She said, all the things you
told me, it wasn't my fault,
I had nothing to be ashamed
of, and more importantly we're
breaking these taboos
and the wall of silence
and talking about
domestic violence,
and you're here
the perfect case.
Because your mother was this
militant feminist, someone
who was on the avant-garde of
the women's movement, and yet
she became a victim
of domestic violence.
So you have to tell your story.
And I still wasn't quite
ready, and then she
did the truly nuclear
option in the Bay Area.
And she said, a lot of people
think that domestic violence
only happens to poor black
women in South Central LA.
And at that point, I was
like, okay, I'll do it.
And I did this interview.
And the night before the
Chronicle article ran,
I was in this law firm.
I was looking at these
beautiful white carpets
and thinking, tomorrow
morning I'm basically
just going to smear
mud on all of them,
because here I am this
lawyer, this professional,
and I'm going to be
talking, telling stories
about being a 10-year-old
crying at my own powerlessness,
at not defending my mother,
and her head being swollen up
to the size of a
melon, and how am I
going to face these people.
And I came in the next morning,
and there was some awkwardness.
One of the male partners who
I worked with for years looked
at me like, this
guy's damaged goods.
I thought I knew you,
and now I don't know you.
But the overwhelming response
that I got from the people
that I worked with was good
for you, you're courageous,
thank you for
telling your story.
And even some of
the women attorneys
who I worked with who
came and spoke to me
and said, something similar
happened in my case,
in my life.
And so that was a very
empowering experience.
And then this movie
"Crime After Crime"
showed-- as Brian said-- at
the Sundance Film Festival.
And it has me talking a little
bit about my experiences,
and all these offers came.
Oh, come speak to our
domestic violence group.
Come speak to this high school.
Come speak here.
So I began speaking about
it, but again as an attorney,
not as a survivor myself.
And then I ended up doing
a spoken word piece talking
about this raw meat interaction
that Debbie and I had,
and this overwhelming sense
of shame and humiliation
at not stepping in
to defend my mother
and for the worst reason.
The reason being that I was
too afraid for my own safety
that I was going to be
killed, which intellectually
I can look back and
say, I was only 10.
What was I really going to do?
But when you're 10, you're
not thinking that way,
and your brain develops around
the idea that you're a coward
and that you're not
doing the right thing.
And so I did a spoken
word piece about that,
and this guy came up
to me in LA afterwards.
He's about 45 years old,
totally ripped, tattooed.
And he comes up and he's
like, hearing you speak,
I know that I'm in an
abusive relationship.
And I'm looking at this guy
like, who is abusing this man?
He looks like a cage fighter.
How can it be?
And as he's telling
me his story,
I begin to understand more.
He says, I never hit the kids.
And I have a son,
and I didn't even
think that he knew
what was happening.
But she gets me so jealous.
She gets me so angry I
can't control myself,
and I don't want my
son to have to end up
like you talking
about this someday.
So I'm going to go back
to my 12 step program,
and I know I can't really
control it anymore.
So I know that now.
And I had this
moment of OK, well
somehow I just affected
this guy's life.
So I'm going to start
to talk about my story.
So my story begins I was born
into a convene of witches
in a commune in the
Haight-Ashbury in 1975.
And when I say the convene of
witches line on the East coast,
people are usually like,
what are you talking about?
Witches?
In San Francisco, people
are like, do you know Dave,
because I know that he grew up
in a-- so I'll throw that out
there.
Witch is not the Halloween
variety of witches,
but rather my mother was
part of a group of women
who were reclaiming religion
from the patriarchy.
They felt that men
and male domination
had derailed religion over
the course of many millennia,
and they were taking it back.
So my first memory as a little
boy was some day I'll grow up,
and I'll have a womb,
and I'll bear a child,
and that'll be the best
thing that I can do.
And they finally broke the
news like, look little man.
You'll never be
able to have a baby.
And then my mother
at a certain point
felt witchcraft is too
organized of a religion.
And she said, I can be
tripping my brains out,
but it still feels like church.
This is too organized.
In 1980, I was coming
of age to go to school,
and my mother felt very
strongly that school
was no place for children.
That was literally
something that she said.
School is no place for kids.
It teaches capitalism, and
competition, and violence.
And this isn't the future that
I want for my young warlock.
She was going to train
me to be a warlock
and a revolutionary leader.
She felt for sure that
the Vietnam War was
going to cause an overthrow
of the US government,
and she was going to be a
leader in that movement.
And when that didn't
happen, she knew
that it was only
a matter of time
until I would be drafted--
because I was a boy--
and sent off to die
for the next lie
that the Man was going to
force upon the American people.
So she wanted to
take to the hills
and raise me to use
my third eye-- the one
that society didn't
want me to know about--
to use my clairvoyance
and psychic powers.
And when the revolution
happened again,
we would descend from the
hills, and I would be a leader.
And so I like to
analogize us to being-- I
don't know if you've seen
the movie-- "Terminator 2"
with Sarah Connor
knowing that there
are these robots
from the future.
Except in our version
of it, there actually
were no robots from the future.
Sarah Connor really was
just off a little bit.
And that was the
way that we grew up,
that I grew up, wandering
from place to place,
different communes, the
Bhagwan Shree Rajneesh people
in Oregon, back to the
land White Native Americans
in Idaho, made their
own buck skin clothing,
all the while without
running water,
without electricity,
toilets, refrigeration.
And the one commonality
that I noticed
with all these various
intentional communities
was whatever their purported
philosophy was, there always
was a strong man who
rose up to be the leader
and eventually took
on a concubine.
And it was right about
the concubine time
that it got weird, and we left.
And we seemed to hit
all these communes right
at concubine time.
So we're moving
from place to place,
and throughout it I
was brought up to never
to call my mother mom or mother.
I called her Claudia.
It would have been sexist and
reductionist to call her mom,
because she was much
more than a mother.
She was a full human being
with a full range of identity
and human expression,
and to just bootstrap her
into that one little identity
would have been wrong.
So I called her
Claudia throughout.
I grew up learning about
herstory not history--
because history,
again, is sexist--
and really spotting all of the
sexism, and racism, and all
of the things that my
mother trained me to see.
And when we would be in these
small towns in rural Oregon,
or Washington, or
Idaho, someone would
be like, what team
are you rooting for.
And my mother's stock
answer was whatever team
has the larger
population of urban poor,
because domestic
violence rates go down
when the home team wins.
That was her philosophy
about-- so she
was very attuned to
all these issues.
However, when I
was nine, she began
doing Central
American amnesty work.
And she believed that the
US backed death squads
in Central America.
US foreign policy in Central
America was the new Vietnam.
It was only a matter
of time until it
was going to escalate
into a full war,
and she was doing this
asylum work getting refugees
from Central America fleeing
these foreign wars that we'd
caused and getting them health
care, and a place to stay,
and that kind of thing
while we were living
on a cabin on a mountain,
a half built cabin
on the side of a mountain.
And she met a man who was 10
years younger than she was,
who was her ideal man.
He was a Che Guevara
figure, a fighter,
a guerrilla commander
from El Salvador,
but also an intellectual,
a poet, a shaman, a healer.
And when she met
him, the spirits
actually said to her, husband.
And he was somebody
pretty special.
And she met this guy.
He told her his is story.
He was crying as he told her
his son had been shot down
in a crossfire in San Salvador.
That turns out to
have been a lie.
But at the time,
it was very real.
And my mother was
captivated by his story,
because he had been tortured
by these death squads
and had survived and escaped,
and he had given up, lost
his family in defending the poor
and helpless in El Salvador.
So she was really
taken in by him.
He was also very muscular,
physically powerfully built guy
who would tell her things
like, sometimes when
I'm talking to you I feel
like all of the suffering
that I went through in my
life was to get me to you,
so I can meet you, this
most beautiful woman
that I've ever met.
And of course, she ended
up taking him to her bed.
And he was a very sensitive
guy, and he cried a lot.
But over time, because he
had PTSD and various trauma
that he'd experienced, he had
nightmares and flashbacks,
and he would sometimes
lash out at her,
slapping her, a black eye
here and there, shoving her,
strange rages.
But this was all part of the
trauma that he'd experienced,
and after all, we
were Americans.
And as Americans, weren't
we somewhat responsible
for US foreign policy?
And we are in some way
responsible for the things
that had happened to him.
So my mother was trying to
do chakra readings on him,
and healing with him,
and counseling with him
to make him better.
And he, of course,
turned to drink,
because alcohol was a way of
masking some of the trauma
that he'd experienced.
And one of his favorite things
to do besides lashing out
at my mother, at that point,
was to fight with cops.
He would go into town, and
he would get in these fights
when he was drunk
with police officers,
in part, because
he always wanted
to know who the real man was.
And with a cop, no one got
to prove one way or another,
because the cops would
cheat-- in his words--
by pulling out a gun
and arresting him
instead of being real
men and fighting him.
So one of these occasions
he was arrested,
and they let him
out when we made
bail, thanks to a generous
gift from my grandmother.
And they revealed to us-- his
public defender reveals to us
that they're going to initiate
deportation proceedings
and send him back
to El Salvador.
He was in the country illegally.
And he reveals to us
that the second his foot
hits that tarmac at Cuscatlan
Airport in San Salvador,
he'll be drilled through
the back of the head
by the death squads
and die right there.
So my mother is faced
with the decision.
Does she want the
man that she loves
to have a death
sentence passed on him--
which is what
deportation would be--
or does she want
to try to help him?
So, of course, she wants to help
him, and the only way that she
can think of to help him is to
marry him, because by marrying
him, that's a path
to citizenship.
So the night before the wedding,
my soon to be stepfather
gets into the box of wine
that we have and just
beats the hell out of my mother
with closed fists in front
of me.
And the next morning there's no
question the wedding will not
be canceled, but it
will be postponed
to allow my mother's face time
to become more recognizable.
So 10 days later,
they're married.
My mother who had never
worn makeup in her life--
because it's sexist for
women to wear make up--
is coated in make up to cover up
her black eye and the swellings
that she still has.
And this man-- Leopoldo is his
name-- becomes my stepfather.
And I talk more about
this in "Free Spirit",
but the next four
years of our lives
are spent surviving and
ultimately overcoming Leopoldo.
As part of this, I decide
I got to go to school.
School is a place
for kids, and perhaps
more importantly,
school is a way
of getting away from this guy,
at least for part of the day.
So at that point, we are finding
ourselves physically more
isolated than we've
ever been before.
We're living on one of the
San Juan islands on the floor,
sleeping on the forest floor
of a temperate rain forest.
And my mother and
stepfather have
salvaged old wooden pallets
from behind a dumpster
at Thrift Foods.
And we're sleeping on the
forest floor on these pallets.
I emerged for my first day
of sixth grade very excited
to go to school covered in
tree sap and pine needles,
wearing old thrift store
clothing that my mother has
patched with blue paisley
fabric here and there.
And as you can imagine, I
get on to the bus like, whoo,
I'm going to school.
And the kids are like, we're
going to kick this guy's ass.
So I'm this total freak.
I get that.
I walk out of the
wall of forest.
So I'm being brutalized by the
kids, having a terrible time.
And there must have been a
riot in the teacher's lounge
when I show up, because
I don't understand
the dynamics of a
classroom, that you have
to raise your hand
to be called upon,
that you can't blurt out
answers, or talk about
feminist theory, critiquing
what the teacher has to say.
And at the same time, while
I have an adult reading
abilities-- I can talk about
Russian literature and world
history-- I don't have any
knowledge of mathematics.
I don't know what a fraction is.
I don't know how to
do multiplication.
I can't read or write in
cursive or longhand, which
was a really big deal to him.
So they didn't know
whether to put me
in remedial classes
or gifted classes.
And one of the teachers finally
steps up, and she says, look,
I will tutor you after school.
You just stay after school.
I'll tutor you.
I can see that you're bright.
I'll help you catch up.
And I say, well, I
can't stay after school.
I got to get back
on that bus that
goes over the bridge
to the island and let's
me off in front of the
forest where we're staying.
And she says, well, your mom
can come and pick you up late.
And I said, well, I can't.
We had a car, but my stepfather
crashed the car into a stump,
and now we don't have a car.
And she said, well,
we'll call your mom.
We'll figure this out.
Well, we don't have a phone, or
any water, electricity, house,
et cetera.
And she says, well,
where are you living?
And I said, well, my stepfather
is chopping down trees.
He's trying to build a pyramid.
He believes in the ancient
occult magic of Egypt,
and he's building us
a wooden pyramid that
will channel this
energy, and it'll
be like a healing
place for us to live.
Needless to say, the
pyramid doesn't happen.
In fact, we are squatting on
some land supposedly owned
by the family of a man named
Crazy John who--as his name
would imply-- is pretty crazy.
My stepfather, in
a drunken rage,
threatens to kill Crazy John
and his pregnant girlfriend.
We're forced to flee the land
that we lived for a short time
in town, which is the first
time with running water
and electricity in a long time.
And in town, not only do
I get to go after school
and be tutored, because
it's walking distance,
but I have access
to public library.
And so, the library
becomes my home.
I'm the biggest champion
of public libraries,
and the little
kindnesses along the way,
and that started me on the
path that led me to you today.
And I think we'll
have some time.
I want to show
you a short video.
It's about three
minutes long that is
a trailer for the
book and my story.
And I also have
some time for Q&A.
But the one takeaway
that I want to say
is one of the things
that got me through that
kept my faith in
human decency were all
those little
kindnesses-- the teachers
and the other
people along the way
who gave me a smile
sometimes or offered to help.
And also one of the
takeaways that I
gained from Debbie, my client.
When I was first
representing her,
she would ask me a lot of
questions about criminal law,
and I would say I don't
know the answers to any
of these questions, because
I don't do criminal law.
I'm a corporate lawyer.
And she finally
said, well, it's OK.
I can't fire you.
There's no one else.
And I laughed, because
that was funny.
There was no one else.
But over time it began
to be a real motivator,
because there was no one else.
If we abandoned Debbie, if we
didn't keep up with her case,
there was no one who was going
to step forward and help her.
And even though I wasn't an
expert in this area of law,
nor was my partner.
The one thing is,
as Brian can attest,
is we just persevered
and stuck with it.
So I want to give that
blessing to all of you,
and say that whatever
it is that you're
passionate about in your lives,
whether it's the work that you
do here, or things
that you do outside,
whether it has to do with
domestic violence or something
else entirely, that
if you just take
that realization that
if you're waiting
for some expert or some
industry guru to come in
and help you in that
issue, they'll never come.
You'll be waiting forever.
There's just you.
There's no one else.
So just engage and persevere.
And if you stick
with it long enough,
you'll be successful
in the way that we
were in getting Debbie out.
So I'll show you this
three minute movie,
and we'll do a Q&A.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Are you the chosen one?
-No, I'm the hungry one.
-The hungry one?
What you want to eat boy?
-A donut.
-A donut?
-I was only six years
old, but I already
wanted more than a donut.
I wanted to be normal, to
live the American dream.
Instead, I got
whatever this is, all
because my mother wanted to
find some place called Utopia.
-Can I go to bed now?
-We hit the open road in 1980.
-When are we going
to get somewhere?
-Utopia could be right
around the corner, Joshie.
Use your third eye, and
we'll get there faster.
-We hitchhiked for five years.
My mother was looking
for a place to call home.
-Here.
This could be our home.
Oh, my god.
This is our home.
-And I was looking for a father.
-Hey, a donut.
-Sir.
-Why is he calling your sir?
-Because he respects me.
-It is perfectly good.
-One of these men
actually cared about me.
-Good move, Josh.
-But my mother chose this guy.
-He's a freedom fighter.
He's going to make an amazing
father to you, Joshie.
-He was the worst
decision she ever made.
-You want to be a man, right?
Like me?
Higher.
Don't lie to me.
-I'm not lying.
-You're lying to me.
What you going to do, huh?
-Jake, take me with you.
-Sir, are you his father
or legal guardian?
-No, but I was--
-Sir, you're going to
have to come with me.
-Josh!
-[INAUDIBLE]!
-Huh, you scared?
-Guns are supposed
to protect you.
-Stop!
-That's all you got?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOSHUA SAFRAN: So
we made that movie
with the producer and director
of "Crime After Crime".
We got together to
make this three minute
trailer with mostly
volunteer cast and crew
of about 100 over six
days, in the Bay Area.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
One, why did the
trial take so long?
And two, is the book both about
your journey and the trial,
or more about your upbringing?
JOSHUA SAFRAN: So the first
question on the trial,
as Brian said, we
thought it would
be relatively straightforward.
There was a new
law passed in 2002
that allowed women who'd been
convicted before California
recognized what was then called
the battered woman's defense.
There were all these women that
we're serving life in prison
and never got to
present that defense.
So I was like, well, if
you can get a lawyer,
the lawyer can present it.
So it took us a couple years
to just establish the evidence
that we needed to show that she
had been battered conclusively.
And we knew at that time
that the LA DA was really
aggressively opposing the
release of all these women,
unlike basically every
other county in California.
Steve was his name.
The LA DA had a real
opposition to these releases.
So we ended up getting 12
percipient witness statements
declarations from all kinds of
people, including neighbors,
and friends of the
batterer, et cetera,
so we felt like we had
a pretty solid case.
That was about two years in.
We went to LA.
We actually met with Steve
Cooley-- the LA DA himself--
and got a plea deal that she
would get out for time served,
because of all
this new evidence.
And not only do we
have it on a handshake,
we had it in writing.
And we unfortunately
ran into what could only
be described as office
politics, believe it or not.
So the woman who was the head
of the Appellate division--
who was nominally in charge
of these kinds of cases--
had never been consulted,
because we accidentally
went to the top
guy, the elected DA.
And she apparently
threw what was
called a political firestorm
and was yelling, and screaming,
and throwing things in the DA's
office, and they got back to us
and said, well, we're
not honoring that.
We are hereby
withdrawing the offer
that you've already accepted,
and we will oppose you.
And at that point, we said,
well, that's unlawful,
and we'll sue you.
And they said, OK, do your best.
So it ended up dragging on and
on, because we had to sue them.
And, of course, the judicial
process is very slow,
and then there were a number of
twists and turns in the case,
including revelations that
not only was Debbie legally
innocent and she had this
battered woman's defense,
but she was actually factually
innocent, didn't do the killing
herself, didn't
engineer the killing.
In fact, the DA's
only witness that
established that was a
paid police informant who
perjured himself on the stand.
The DA's office knew about it.
So it snowballed into this
bigger and bigger case,
until finally a judge held
that they were circling
the wagons to protect their
professional reputations.
So the case really
for them became
about covering up misdeeds,
because their own people
were going to be
fired, or worse,
if the truth came
out in this case.
So that was why the case
ended up taking so long.
And it was a lead case in
this battered women's law
in California and looked
to in various other states
as to the entire
criminal justice system,
how can this happen, how is
this going to work, et cetera.
So that was that answer.
The book is really more just
my childhood story, basically
from 0 to 12.
And then I have a
chapter where I tie it
into that work on that case.
And I think it wasn't really
until I wrote the book that I
really realized much
of my motivation
really, at least
in taking the case,
but also in sticking
with it is that,
again, the strange
feeling of powerlessness.
And somehow this case
in a very real way
allowed me to prove to myself
at least that, oh, yeah, I
can do something.
I can do what's right.
And as I thought
about it, I thought
what I really wanted when
I graduated from law school
and as I was becoming a
man was a time machine.
I just wanted for
whatever-- you have
these experiences in your life,
you want to go back in time,
and help yourself
or help someone.
And since I didn't have
time traveling capability,
maybe Google will develop that.
But at the time, that
wasn't available to me.
So I thought well, the next best
thing is I can become a lawyer,
and find people who
are similarly situated,
and help them, and that
will metaphorically
fix what I went through.
AUDIENCE: So what part does
religion play in your life?
JOSHUA SAFRAN: That's
a great question.
Religion played a very
important role for me.
As you heard, I was brought
up with star gazers,
and constellation
worshipers, and pagans.
But more than anything, I
was brought up with nothing.
Even at the most remote
areas of the counterculture,
beyond on the perimeter, people
still celebrated Christmas.
I mean, you could be an Indian
guru somewhere up in Oregon,
but you would still have a
Christmas tree, and an Easter
egg hunt, and all that.
My mother didn't
have any of that.
So we had absolutely nothing.
And unlike everyone else
who was from somewhere,
my mother didn't know
where we were from.
And I, at one point, talked to
my grandmother-- her mother--
and said, where are we from?
My grandmother said, who knew?
And I was like,
surely you must know
where the family came from.
Who knew?
They kept changing the borders.
So it was this sense
of we're from nowhere.
We don't believe in anything.
And I had a very
innate spiritual sense.
I went through a lot of
life or death experiences
and really did feel at times
that I was being shepherded
by some otherworldly force,
but I had no vocabulary for it.
So when I was nine,
my mother and I
were living on the
side of this mountain,
and we passed a
cabin down the trail.
And this guy who was-- I
don't know exactly what
he did-- but he lived in
Seattle, his vacation home,
When he wanted to
get away from it all,
he came and lived by our
main house where we lived.
And my mother started
talking to him and, he said,
where are you from?
And my mother said, oh,
we're from San Francisco.
And he goes, ain't no
landsman from the Bay Area,
no Jews from San Francisco.
And my mother laughs, and said,
how'd you know we were Jewish.
And he said, look at your kid.
He's got a rabbi's nose.
And they started
talking and laughing.
And finally he ended
his little soliloquy,
and he said, so I must have
been the only Italian kid
in Brooklyn with not one,
but two bar mitzvahs.
And my mother thought this
was hilarious, and we left.
And it was this strange moment
for me, where all of sudden
there was some history.
This guy new things about
us, and strange places,
and things beyond east
of the Mississippi.
So when we got out into
the darkening mist,
I asked my mother,
what are we again?
That guy knew about us,
and my nose, and something.
Aw yeah, we're Jews.
What does that mean?
Well like Freud,
Einstein, Marks, Jews.
So I thought about that.
I was like, we're
related to them?
Sort of.
Then she gave me a
good Jewish answer.
She said, we should go to
the library and look it up.
So when I finally got into
town and I went to the library,
I really went in with no sense
of what I was looking for
and came away with this
Encyclopedia Britannica
introduction, which was so we're
descended from this ancient
tribe that wrote the Bible and
introduced the world to God
and is supposed to shine like
a beacon of righteousness.
But the thing that
really touched me
about the Jewish story
that I read in this library
was that it mimicked my own
life, this nomadic wandering
from place to place,
perpetually demeaned,
and discriminated against
by various people,
yet still thriving and
living by your wits.
And that really
resonated with me.
So I think that was
my introduction.
And then as part of
that, I went and talked
to my mother, who
then told me that she
had given up a
child for adoption.
When she was a
teenager, she briefly
dated a Colombian
Marxist revolutionary
and had given up this
baby for adoption,
and somewhere in New Jersey
I had a half brother.
And somehow in my mind that
was that he was probably living
a Jewish life, because it
was New Jersey after all.
And everyone in New
Jersey must be Jewish.
And so I had this sense
that somewhere out there
were my people-- I didn't
know who or where they were--
and someday he would
clasp me by the arm,
and pull me up out of this
smashing and screaming,
and take me home.
So that became part
of my own mythology.
And then spiritually, a
couple years later, my mother
had dated a Rastafarian
Mennonite-- which
to give the picture--
no mustache,
but chin beard and dreadlocks.
And he made this mixtape
of reggae music for me.
And so, my mother was obsessed
with Coltrane, and Miles Davis,
and this amazing jazz, which
was very traumatic for me
to listen to.
But reggae really
appealed to me.
It had this melodic
spiritual sound to it.
And we're around
the campfire, and I
was singing this Bob
Marley song, "the stone
that the builder refuse shall
be the head cornerstone".
And I didn't know what
a head cornerstone was,
but I knew that I had been the
stone that the builder refused,
and that spoke to me.
And so I'm singing that
song, and my mother says,
oh, that's from Psalms.
And I was like, this isn't
some weird bible thing.
This is Bob Marley,
roots, truth.
And my Mom, no, no.
She had this book, which
I called the Tonach, which
was the Tondach--
the Hebrew Bible.
So she gave me this book,
and I'm looking through.
And I find the book
of Psalms and end up
reading the whole thing
to just disprove her,
because at that
point in my life,
I'd rejected everything
that she was about.
I thought, yes, you can hug
a child with nuclear arms.
Like everything that she
believed in was wrong.
So I started working my way
through the book of Psalms
to disprove her.
I found out that she was right.
That was a line from Psalms.
But I also read
Psalms is the poetry
of King David, a young man
in the wilderness crying out
for help.
And as I read that
book, I was like, this
is like my experience.
I'm really resonating with this.
So that really became a
spiritual path for me, as well.
And it provided the vocabulary
for the things that I
was feeling, and a
sense of belonging,
and a sense of identity.
And at a certain
point, my mother said,
you're basically going
to be subscribing
to a rule based
patriarchal religion.
And I thought about it.
I was like, well, I had
no rules and no father,
so that sounds about right.
So that was that part
of my path began there.
AUDIENCE: I have read the first
two chapters of your book.
You're an amazing writer.
JOSHUA SAFRAN: Thank you.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So do you have other
plan to write more books?
JOSHUA SAFRAN: Yeah, I do.
I am working on a book proposal
for the sequel right now.
So you'll see when you get
to the end of the book,
it ends at 12 with us
running into this commune
by the Canadian border
in a school bus.
And so it connects that kid
to being arrested a few times
and being unsure
whether I was going
to make it out to making it out.
And thank you.
I appreciate that.
AUDIENCE: You talk a little bit
about why you became a lawyer,
and it seems very disconnected
with what you ended up
doing as your primary source
of income as a lawyer.
I am also a corporate lawyer, so
take that with a grain of salt.
But how did you become
a corporate lawyer?
And were you ever able to
find more fulfillment in that
than the Fortune 500
battle of 20 million?
JOSHUA SAFRAN: Yeah, so
I had twin aspirations
in going to law school.
Part of it was I
still to this day
am actually offended
by lawyer jokes,
because I still at least
have a perception in my mind
most lawyers are these guardians
of justice doing great work.
How can you make that joke?
And I'm sad that that's
probably not true.
So I did have this sense,
both in my own personal life
as far as criminal
defense attorneys who
played an important role in my
life to keeping me out of jail,
for example.
I had a great
respect for lawyers,
and I really saw them as
these uniquely capable people,
because they had the
monopoly of knowledge
on how to navigate
the system, and yet
were down dealing with
people like us who
are outside of that system.
So they were these
warriors, really.
So that was on the one side.
And the other side
is when you grow up
with no running water,
electricity, and everything
else, or sugar, or television,
that's all you want.
You can guarantee that
your child will rebel.
So for me, as I
was looking around,
I was like, OK, who
are successful people?
And I had this lawyer thing,
and oh, yeah, lawyers do well.
Lawyers can-- that's a big deal.
That's a respectable thing.
So that was my motivation.
And then when I
got to law school,
I had this amazing awful moment,
which you may have experienced.
Or you may have
experienced where
you're like, I'm going to do
justice, and you're like, wow,
you have to live in a
trailer and eat canned beans
to do the nonprofit work.
But these people will
pay you over six figures
to just do whatever.
That's awesome.
And for me I was truly excited
about that opportunity.
And to be totally
clear, I loved it.
I mean, I still to this day take
10 minute showers, and I mean,
I just love having everything.
I gained a ton of weight,
because I could eat doughnuts,
and it was great.
See, I blame everything
on my childhood.
But no, so I mean, I was
enjoying all of that.
And I loved all that that
got me, but at the same time
I think the hours expectations
in these big corporate firms
are such that they don't
want you to do anything
but be a corporate lawyer.
And so I think that
was really the--
I still have great
respect for people
who can integrate pro bono work
into their corporate practice.
I mean, it's righteous.
For me, I ended up--
sadly when people
say this movie must have been
so great for your career.
I'm like, it destroyed
my partnership prospects,
and I got fired.
But that's what happened.
I was at the firm, I
was up for partner,
and they said, look dude,
you do way too much pro bono.
You need to be
kicking up your hours.
And it's great you're
representing this woman,
but enough already.
It's been eight years.
So at that point, I left and
still was working on her case
actually.
And then I was lucky enough that
my current day job-- the Port
of Oakland called, and I
had been representing them
as outside counsel.
And they said, come in-house.
And I was, well, I'll
need all these days off
for my parole hearings.
And they're like, what
are you talking about?
You're like the
aviation, land use,
all of these areas of
expertise I had cultivated.
And I explained it
to the person who
was I thought about
not to give me a job.
And much credit to my boss who
then said, that sounds really
righteous, this case
that you're working on.
I'll make a deal with you.
And I was like, OK, what's
this deal going to be?
He's like, when you get her
out, you bring her up here,
and we'll have a lunch for her.
And I was like, all right.
Good deal.
I'm a government lawyer,
so it has worked out.
Well the one other
thing that I'll
say just because I know that
maybe my mother-- this very
interesting character but also
a very interesting person-- we
grew up together.
When I went to college,
my mother went to college.
When I got a job, she got a job.
I had years of
resentment and anger
to her for what I
began to perceive
as the unnecessary deprivation
that we had to go through.
In a way, I could almost forgive
her for the domestic violence
years, because I understood
the dynamic of how
we'd gotten in there
and how we got out.
But all the other
stuff, the deprivation.
And then I got to
college, and I'm
meeting all these kids who grew
up in cul-de-sacs and suburbs,
eating sugar, watching
television, having hot showers,
all the rest of it,
and I get to college,
and they're like this sucks.
I don't want to be here.
This is lame, and my
mother never loved me,
and my father likes
my brother more.
And they never had any domestic
violence or anything else,
but they were
totally bummed out.
And I'm in college
thinking, this
is the greatest
experience of my life.
I can just go to
the dining hall,
and there's just as
much food as you want.
It's like Google.
You can take these showers.
You watch television.
You can do anything.
I was just like,
this is amazing.
I was loving it.
And so part of me
was like, well,
there's different ways
of judging a parent,
but I always felt like
my mother loved me.
I always felt like
she was like, you
can do anything you want to do.
You can be anyone
you want to be.
She may not have supervised me.
But she loved me.
And so I began to
recalibrate my own feelings
toward my mother at that point.
And she, around that
time, said, I turned on,
tuned in, dropped out, but
I'm finally crawling back.
And that was her
sense, that she was
going to rejoin-- she was
going to wave the white flag.
The revolution was
not coming tomorrow,
and she was going to
rejoin American society.
Now that said, when the whole
Occupy Movement was happening,
my mother was like,
oh, this could be it.
Get ready.
So she's still looking
forward to the revolution,
but she also has a mortgage.
So it's been an
interesting relationship.
And my wife and I, we
actually trust her.
She comes and babysits.
We have three daughters.
But it's like, we come back.
It's 10:00 at night.
All the lights in
the house are on.
None of the girls are in bed.
One of them is missing.
One's watching something
on the computer.
Who knows what?
And she's playing the
maracas with the youngest.
So she's still pretty spirited,
but has really come a long way.
And we still have a
very close relationship.
Yeah, so I mean, I think one
of the things that surprised me
when I began part
of my strange arc.
We all have our weird arcs,
but my weird arc was the thing
that you're most
ashamed of is going
to be your defining
characteristic, which
is-- if you think about what
that is in your life, that's
a really weird thing
to have happened.
So it happened to me.
I didn't want to ever
talk about this issue that
had happened to me.
And there was just
this thirst to have
me come speak
about these issues.
And a big part of that has
been the fact that I'm a man,
and I didn't realize
this until I got into it.
But the perception out there
is that domestic violence
is a women's issue.
It's women get in
these relationships,
and women get battered, and
women do leave or don't leave,
and whatever.
But there's this whole missing
equation of for every victim,
there's a perpetrator.
And this identity of, wait a
second, why isn't it a man's
issue?
So a lot of the work that
I've been trying to do
is to talk about--
especially with young guys--
what it means to
be a man, and what
it means to stand up for someone
who's weaker than you are,
and not to bully them.
And I think that one of the
strange realizations that I've
had-- that the science
shows, of course--
is that the
perpetrators, the men who
are in these abusive
relationships, the batterers
were themselves victims, or
at least children in homes
where this was happening.
So there's this
strange arc where
these boys, like me, who you
can be very sympathetic to,
and say, OK, well,
it's not their fault.
They're a child.
It's not their fault.
Now it's their fault.
They're now 17 and in an
abusive relationship themselves.
And the way that the human
mind works with these boys who
are seeing what
happens, part of what's
going on in their head is
they're thinking, well,
what's wrong in this
equation is not necessarily
that he's beating
my mother or running
the house like a tyrant.
What's wrong is that
I'm not the alpha.
I'm not the king, but
someday I will be.
And then it will be OK,
because I'll be in control.
And it's about breaking
that whole cycle,
and it really is this
a generational notion.
And the last thing I
will say about that
is if you think the statistics
are that somewhere between one
in four and one in three
women will experience this
in their lifetimes, which means
roughly the same number of men
will be involved.
And if you think
about it hard enough,
you can probably think either
an experience that you've had,
obviously, but a neighbor,
a friend, a colleague who
you suspect, oh, yeah, this may
be happening in their lives.
I think the greatest
mistake is to be like, well,
that's a private matter.
I'm not going to pry.
I think we all have a
sense of how far you
can pry before you're committing
a crime, some kind of stalking
or something.
I don't want you to do that.
But at the same time, that you
really do need to speak up.
You do need to get involved,
and you will be surprised
that when you do, people, I
think, will react in such a way
that you're really glad
and happy that you did.
And when you
intervene, it does help
to break that cycle of violence.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much, Joshua.